if you're going to build something big
it's not you doing everything it's you
hiring people to do things and you're in
charge of the following framework higher
fast if they prove to you in the first 3
6 or 12 months they stink fire faster if
they prove to you in the first 3 6 or 12
months they got it promote fastest more
than anything I do in my life I've been
wrong in hiring it's just a hard game
but the reason I built massive companies
is because I have fired faster in my
older age cuz I really struggled with it
in my youth and now I'm promoting
fastest for the last decade and it's
been gamechanging winners like to be
seen and you trying to hold it off
because you don't want them to think
they're too big of a winner like small
businesses listen I get it every dollar
count so I can wait a year before I
promote and the money if you got a
winner lock it in